okay all right thanks very much thanks
for the opportunity to be here
I'll be talking a little bit about
genome graphs and we'll start with the
motivation so right now you have a sorry
this is taken from a longer talk you
have a situation where yeah we tell you
someday about what the first two
examples were so right now we have a
reference genome that is just one
representative of each of the human
chromosomes taken arbitrarily from an
individual in some cases it's a chimeric
or parts of it were taken from different
individuals that creates a bias which is
well known now reference bias so when
you're looking at mapping millions and
billions of reads as we do every day
turns out there's a systematic bias so
if you're from an ethnicity that has
different versions of regions of the
genome then your reads will not map
against the standard reference as well
as others who are from that where that
region is from the ethnicity that was
used in the reference we can't really
tolerate this on a global standard so
many different groups are establishing
their own reference genomes now but if
you think about this process it's doomed
to lead to some kind of crazy Tower of
Babel so we want to think about
representing all of human genetic
variation in one consistent reference
data structure and that's what this
about and we're going to call it a
genome graph so it should include all
common variants down to a certain level
of frequency say 1% that occur in any of
the ethnic groups that represent our
human population and we'll think of it
as a graph we can illustrate that in a
minute now this is of enormous research
utility but it is absolutely essential
for the clinical application of genomics
which right now we're going through
a process in which many genome
technologies are now applying for
approval by the FDA by the clinical the
CLIA certification process and in other
countries the equivalent processes so
that they can be used to actually make
clinical decisions these have to be then
be a rigorous test which gives a
well-defined answer the problem with
this is that most of these tests when
they're after actually seeking a genetic
variation will produce the answer in one
of many many different types of forms so
there are a number of different
databases and efforts that have been
established to name the different human
variants and they again we have this
Tower of Babel problem especially
because some of them focus on certain
types of variants like single nucleotide
substitutions or just substitutions of a
few bases some of them focus on larger
structural changes and we have an
enormous incompatibility and this is
right now the major problem holding us
back from clinical application of
genomics on a routine basis it's still a
research project because we haven't
sorted this out so what we need is some
kind of a rosetta stone that will allow
us to think about all of these different
representations of different segregating
human genomes that are that are that are
moving around in the population and all
of the different reference the different
variations that they occur that occur on
them so a simple idea is to take
individual chromosomes which
biologically of course are linear
objects and then merge the identical or
common parts of them and leave the
different parts as different paths
through a graphical structure so if you
can imagine that the current reference
genome is represented by this bold red
line that represents a long sequence of
a C's T's and G's perhaps through this
the MHC or major histocompatibility
complex region which holds holds on
chromosome six about a three or so mega
base region that that has most of our
immune genes in it
that one representation is actually a
bad representation for this green
chromosome which deviates from it quite
a bit so if we zoom in on to this
looking from the going from the three
mega base scale down to the lower scale
where now we're looking at essentially
close to individual bases we can see
then the detailed process that you get
as you compare genomes zooming in a
little bit further we see that at the
individual base level this red path had
a typical segment for this genome GC CAG
we see that there are alternate paths
where the CA is replaced by a GT or
where the where the CC is replaced by a
T and so forth so these are referenced
as paths through this graph of DNA and
each of these positions or in general
segments of positions that are useful in
clinical applications will have a unique
machine readable identifier along with
the usual clinical names but the idea is
that this identifier would be permanent
the worst mistake we ever made was to
start identifying these as positions
that are offset from the beginning of
the chromosome I often say that if my
PhD computer science student had a debt
had designed that data structure in that
way of representing places in the human
genome they would have gotten an F on
their assignment and the reason for that
is that these locations are changing all
the time as we learn more about the
genome most of the genomes have regions
that are unresolved and this will remain
so for quite a while
the centromeric regions were for for
example but we on this horrible
situation that if in the
current reference genome we realized
that there's another base upstream for
this and we change we go from grch38 to
seven to 38 then the coordinates in
absolute offsets of all of these change
utterly useless as a identifier but this
permanent identifier may be a UUID like
object can remain for decades so we need
to name this variation with a local name
that has a meaning within the graph that
does not change as we learn more about
human genetic variation which we will
inevitably do so we add to this graph
rather than subtracting from it
if there's something you really think
that was bogus in the graph circa
2016 you can mark it as as as suspected
or bogus but you never really take
anything away so we are proposing to
build this graph systematically so I
will look in this talk in detail about
what we mean by the graph what kind of
graphs we built and how we're evaluating
them and this work proceeds you know you
know with us with a very simple
definition there were a lot of fancy
definitions and discussion about how to
represent these graphs but the community
I would say settled on a very very
simple definition rather than the
pictures that I was showing where you
were you were thinking about a data
structure that would represent
individual bases for reasons of
efficiency we're allowing the objects in
the node to contain entire strings of
DNA the other so the nodes of the graph
will be strings of DNA in some default
orientation like if you look at
chromosome 1 it's oriented from the P
arm to the Q arm by default and then in
between these segments of DNA you have
these things called joins and the joins
come off one end or the other so this is
not an abstract node but it has
effectively a three prime end and a five
prime end or a left and a right end to
it
that means informally that these edges
could be by directed
Edge's if you represent this as a simple
graph note then the edge has to contain
the information that says which end of
the note you're attaching to but whether
you put that information in the note or
the edge we we you know by by making two
nodes out of this effectively we don't
care so conceptually that's it now DNA
is great it's like a railroad track that
you can go either way on and so you can
have a connection from one end of this
note say I mean normally a path would
would go tend to go left to right
through this structure but we do not
want to demand that is it directed a
cyclic structure because we do have
cases like inversions that are possible
changes in the DNA as represented here
so I could have the DNA a CG ACGT GGG T
and blah blah blah like this or if this
is inverted in some people I could have
the DNA that goes T G G and then goes
over here and then starts traversing
backwards through this by TT Ge Ge G and
so forth reading the reverse complement
and then picks up here and continues on
so it's important the the the
double-stranded part of DNA is baked
into the graph and its interpretation
okay so that's it the genome graph is
just a bunch of nodes connected by
joints simple as that each node has a as
a DNA sequence in a default orientation
which tells what the ends are now the
project that I'll be talking about was
sponsored by or organized by the Global
Alliance for genomics and health and a
couple of words about that really
quickly it is an organization that is a
non-governmental not-for-profit
organization founded by myself and seven
other individuals about three years ago
and its mission is simply to help the
world share genomic data and we're
talking about sharing not in terms of
privacy policies in this talk which are
which are a big part of the Global
Alliance but in terms about sharing
information in particular variants in a
precise form and a durable form all of
the work at the Global Alliance is done
on this github site if you're not
familiar with it or you're interested in
it just go on the github site there are
hundreds approximately 430 contributors
right now to this large open source
project all groups are welcome to
participate if you look at what happens
in a day to day basis and I get huge
email threads from this decisions are
made all the time according to Apache
open-source foundation rules basically
you make poll requests to modify the
schemas or the code if you get three
plus ones from your from other people
working on the code without any minus
ones then the pull request is executed
in the code marches forward so the code
gets developed the leadership is totally
determined by the amount of contribution
so these the people who contribute are
the people who organized the hackathons
the meetings and make decisions about
direction and we have of the 385
organizations in the Global Alliance
more than 120 of them are private
companies so this is a way in which
private companies can be part of the
standards making for the area that they
work in and these include lots of small
companies new DNA analysis and genomics
companies that you've all heard of
they're dozens of them just in the Bay
Area plus big companies Google is in
there Amazon is in there Microsoft is in
there so we have a lot of work from all
different types of companies they all
are collaborating on the interface they
all plan to compete on the
implementation once the API is settled
we're anticipating we're at API 0.6 at
this point we're anticipating a 1.0 API
by the end of the year so what about
this genome graph idea this is an idea
that is in a second phase so this will
be in API 2.0 actually but we are in
parallel as we work on
the current API developing the next
generation and we have a number of
groups that have provided genome graphs
in an agreed-upon schema in format and
they are now you can actually
interrogate them and use them through
the Global Alliance servers and apply
various many evaluations so people are
building these three parts of it
independently but interoperable the
regions that we chose to look at are the
brca1 gene the brca2 gene these are the
most famous genes for breast cancer
susceptibility the SMA regions this is a
muscular atrophy region that's quite
complicated in terms of its duplication
and rearrangement structure the keyer
region which is a killer cell immune
associated region also very complicated
in terms of copy number and the major
histocompatibility complex region we are
starting to do the centromere but I
won't be talking about that so here are
the groups that participated in our
first organized graph building and
comparison and the methods that they
used so how do you build a graph from
DNA sequences basically the idea is to
take the DNA sequences and merge parts
of them that you are going to treat as
identical within your graph so then you
get a kind of merging and diverging
railroad tracks graph from your DNA many
people start then with a multiple
sequence alignment which suggests places
which might be identical and in the
corresponding positions to be merged
other extremes we had groups that just
use a de bruyne graph so the nodes in
the graph were all 63 mer for the k
equals 63 note Moritz every node is a is
a 63 mer and you have to adjust it
because in the de bruyne graph the notes
over overlap a little bit in our in our
graph here they don't but that's e it's
easy to transform it so there are many
different approaches is given on here
the last approach which I'll mention is
this thousand genomes
this is built by Eric garrison at the at
the Saenger and it simply takes the
reference genome and adds an alternate
path for every variant in the thousand
genomes VCF file so the thousand genomes
project has a lot as documented many
many human variations each one you can
think of if you look in the VCF record
as aligning to the main primary path of
grch38 then doing something different
and then rejoining we call that a bubble
sometimes if you put in a bubble for all
the snips essentially and you get that
the Simon's diverse genome diversity
project has produced a similar set but
with much more ethnic diversity globally
over 200 different ethnic populations
and so we did the same thing with that
actually with Eric so now if you break
down these grafts and you try to view
them not at the DNA base level but at a
little higher level they look something
like this so that 341 is 341 bases of
DNA in here that I'm not going to show
you explicitly and this is a typical
snip so we have one version of it that's
and the blue is usually representing the
primary or grch38 reference and this
would represent a snip that's present in
the thousand genomes set for example
this this is Benedict Payton's who's
Mike my co-speaker here I may call in
him for some of the details so he's
leading the project and he also designed
his own graph methodology called cactus
and so this is one way of deciding
essentially this all comes down to
deciding when to merge and when to keep
things separate and so algorithms for
doing that are still you know there are
many different approaches and we were
testing them camel is another approach
to do that based on a methodology that I
talked about here a while back which was
context dependent sequence matching and
then this is a third method so these
graphs look pretty left-to-right but if
you look at the de bruyne graph
especially at k31
it's very much not a left or right kind
of thing it's a very much a hairball
kind of spaghetti graph as you can see
in this depiction here now the de bruyne
graph with 63 is a little more like this
like the other graphs that we see that
were built by multiple alignments this
there's no alignment in this de bruyne
construction obviously you're just
looking at the content of segments of
DNA
so in brca2 you can see graphs that are
made by just the BRCA data that we
provided for this exercise so everybody
was encouraged to use to try to make a
graph out of some initially completely
independent sequences for BRCA BRCA the
region that we chose for BRCA 2 is about
whoops is about 85,000 bases and so you
can think about you know one
representation of it would be just one
block you can think about this as
representing other variants of it in a
very very high-level mechanism for
instance this graph SBG by key reverse
has a representation where there's there
they use very very large blocks and then
you explicitly kind of tile across and
try to get variation between those so
there will be an enormous amount of data
in here that's very very you know that
normally would be incredibly well
aligned and you might be tempted to
merge but then of course you lose
phasing when you merge too much and so
this is an extreme trade-off of I really
don't want to merge I want to keep a lot
of big stuff separate the tiling paths
that key reverse used is represented in
kind of a tiling array diagram where
they will have large sequences that they
will choose one of these large sequences
even if there are some parts of them
that match they will choose separate
paths for these and then make a kind of
a
a switching decision at some point so in
the comparisons that I will give you
shortly there are some control graphs or
default graphs first off there is the
graph for brca1 that just represents
that region of its chromosome in hgr 38
so this is so hgr 38 just with it's
single chromosomes is a graph it's just
there's just one path in the graph there
are also the set that we gave everybody
of fully sequenced different versions of
the BRCA gene and one thing you can do
is not merge anything so this is a graph
it just has three different ways to go
all the way through the BRCA region so
this is this has the variation that you
would get and then there's also for the
ones that do the fancy merging in
particular there's a whole class of bees
that said fine you gave us these
examples of BRCA 38 but I'm going to go
to the thousand genomes project and add
in all the variants there as well so you
had to tell us if you were doing this
but you were allowed to go to other
sources and make your graph even richer
and when you do that you get these bumpy
graphs and in order to see what the
bumpiness did we have this control graph
which simply takes all the bumps and
shifts them over by 200 bases so you
have complete nonsense set of snips but
it controls for the topology of the
graph and it's apology of the graph is
identical but it has nothing to do with
biology alright so what do you get
cactus fun merge this is on the key
region this killer cell region and at
zoomed way out know this you get some
you get some interesting hairballs shows
you the enormous structural variation
that you can obtain when you start
merging similar regions between genomes
in the
and MHC ouch okay so there is a lot of
complicated similarity throughout MHC
and it's easy to over merge it these you
know these are situations where you know
things can be improved by heuristics so
one of the things you might ask is what
is the basic structure of these graphs
so every base in the graph has a degree
essentially of how many other bases it's
connected to now if it's a base within
one of those segments that's one because
you have to go linearly across the
segment but when you and reach the end
of one of these nodes you may have one
choice to choice zero choice sometimes
so these are the average number of
choices that you have after a base
including the limits excuse me in the
sequences and you see it's very close to
one and for some of these we maybe get
up to 1.0 3 and the different graphs
have different branching as' and and
these are the five different regions
that are shown here so the regions are
branch ear and some and then the graphs
or branch or than some compression is
just asking you if I add up all of the
bases in these are photographs that were
built from the training examples if I
add up all of the bases in this these
training sequences and compare that to
the number of bases in the final graph
what have I got in terms of compression
so compression by a factor of two would
have shrunk the graph in size factor of
two most of the graphs are compressing
occasionally some are decompressing so
that's an interesting phenomenon we
looked at another topological way to
measure the linearity of this graph so
if you imagine as most graphs that we
can lay out the graph by assigning
positions of all the bases from left to
right so they've been all of the all of
the arcs then are interpreted as going
along a linear distance
then you can ask for any different any
position in this topological sort or
linearly linear ordering of the basis of
the graph how many edges cross that so
in a very simple linear graph with just
one it would always be one edge crossing
this but in this case where we have two
alternates as snip then when we
linearize this we're going to put one of
them on one side and one on the other
and so there will be two two edges
crossing these cut so cut width is at a
particular cut is how many edges cross
that cut and we're interested in the
average cut with now we topologically
sorted the notes you might ask did we
sort them to it were in an order that
minimizes the average cut with but we
didn't do that because we looked at dick
carps paper and it showed that basically
that was np-complete right this goes
back quite a ways so we have a heuristic
topological sort to do this so if you
look at the average cut with these are
just some calculations of this there's
two crossing here two crossing here two
crossing here one crossing here and so
we get an average cut width out of that
okay so this is the cut with
calculations and this was a big surprise
because this is now a log the
logarithmic scale base ten so we had cut
widths that were a hundred times higher
in some graphs versus the others which
is very interesting all right so there
is a lot of variation and what people
think are sensible way of merging this
data into a graph you can rapidly get
enormous cut with versus small cut width
again we have to try as many heuristic
algorithms for ordering nodes as
possible to make sure this isn't an
artifact of a bad ordering but
I know it's normalized yeah yeah it
shouldn't be less than one it's that
some kind of scale shift so the other
measure that we did so those are just
kind of the topological features of the
graph what do they look like how big
there's how big they are
that was the compression relative to the
starting data the branch enos and the
cut width so the other thing we want to
talk about is how well they represent
the raw data that we're trying to
capture one simple measurement is just
to look at the Kaymer's in the raw data
and see if those Kaymer's are
represented as little paths somewhere in
the graph then we would say that the
graph recalls that Kaymer that it should
on the other hand if you compress
everything like crazy
down to like de bruyne 2 or 3 then
you're going to have paths for tons of
Kaymer's that aren't really represented
even in a large data set like the
thousand genomes project so that would
be a lack of precision so precision if
you get hit on precision that means
you've got too many k-mers in your graph
more than or biologically plausible as
common alleles and lack of recall means
that you're leaving out actual human
Kaymer's that should be in your graph
here is a plot of precision versus
recall for the various graphs and you
can see we do quite well so in terms of
recall most of the graphs are capturing
on the MHC region 99% of the Kaymer's
that they should be capturing and at a
very high precision over here now some
of them fall off as you go through this
thing but these are an example of the
trade-offs now the control graph is
horrible in the sense that it it creates
a lot of k-mers that are garbage and
misses the ones that it should the
primary sequence itself so this is where
we are now with grch38 is missing a huge
amount so it's very poor on recall that
which is not surprising right it doesn't
contain
variation that we want to capture if you
look at the RCA - this tightens up a bit
so now we're at 0.99 six or seven up
here for these graphs that are
performing well still at a very nice
precision yes what was K 20 I believe
right Benedicte k equals 20 for this
yeah you can do that we did these for
various K's these are just sample graphs
so read mapping okay a more realistic
actual field test we want to map reads
to this graph everybody Maps reads to
the reference genome but now you can map
reads to the graph does that help major
question so what we did was took a bunch
of thousand genomes reads that were bwa
mem aligned so they already had a
canonical alignment to the reference
genome grch38 and we tried to map those
to our graph using a algorithm that i
won't go into the details of but it's
Eric Garrison's vge algorithm which is
smart enough to map to a graph instead
of having a map to a linear sequence
which is all I'm gonna say about it this
is one of the nicer results now what
you're seeing here is the portion of
those bwa mem reads that were actually
uniquely mapped goes up from 80 to 90%
within the graph and this is the portion
that were perfectly mapped now there's a
certain threshold of error in the data
because you can't perfectly map if
there's an if there's actual mistake in
the read and the error rate is like 1%
or a little bit more than 1% out of
these 150 120 base reads and so your
your threshold is up here just a little
ways you're the noise is not going to
prevent you from getting perfect mapping
higher than a certain amount
and unique mapping of course is going to
depend heavily on how much you collapse
right if you under collapse you're going
to map to different places so what was
beautiful about this I think is that you
get more perfectly mapped and more
uniquely mapped so this is a win-win
it's not a trade-off graphs are just
better so we were very happy with this
this means that when you had a place to
perfectly map it you found it and then
that was the only place you mapped in a
well merged graph so win-win there's a
very very strong argument I think that
graphs will be good this is for brca2
now the numbers get higher but the
differences in performance get lower the
vrs brca2 is a much less challenging
region yes yes there's one unique place
that minimizes the error okay so now the
last thing I'll talk about and which is
loops back to our very first topic I
said the motivation for this is that so
we can call variants in a way that is
medically rigorous and that the
authorities will certify as being
rigorous enough to make a medical
decision based on so we need to be able
to call variants in genomes very
precisely so we look at this general way
of doing it again this is in Eric
Garrison's VG pipeline all of those
tools became a kind of common core for a
lot of what the graph group did you
start out with a read alignment and then
you can look at a pile up at a certain
region on that and you may have a snip
for example you may have an a here and C
here so you're going to get a pile up of
different reads and you will see to what
extent those reads can match a path in
this graph now that's interesting and so
based on that you can call two variants
here one path that goes this way a one
path that goes this way but what's
interesting is you may also have a place
where there's another
that where you cannot exactly match a
set of reads which you think is real to
either of these paths and in that case
you have to do what we call an
augmentation to the path so our
philosophy is that the and we know every
genome is going to contain novel
variation that's not been seen before so
you have to handle novel variation when
you think you have novel variation what
you do is you take the canonical
reference graph that you've built and
you add another path to represent that
so therefore you have an Augmented graph
for which every very you're gonna call
is a path in your augmented graphs
you've added structure in order to name
your variants if you want to think about
it that way ok that's called an
augmentation of the graph and then from
that you make your calls now how would
you call this augmentation you you might
have canonical names for all of these
paths this augmentation path would have
to say basically I go along to here and
then I go to a new DNA sequence and then
I rejoin the graph here so there is a
canonical name for that so if two people
discovered the same augmentation
independently if it's an augmentation of
the same base graph they can recognize
that they both discovered the new
Augmented variant and in fact this is
how we envision that new variants would
gradually be added to the genome right
because people are augmenting them like
crazy and finally they say well let's
just put it in the reference everybody
needs this augmentation ok so you got
the idea of augmentation alright so what
we did was compute
various heuristics and so forth and
output what was essentially a sample
graph which only contains that part of
the of the genome that's actually
exercised by the sample so going back to
this picture this might be part of a
very very large augmented graph but now
when you're looking at the particular
DNA sample that you're trying to find a
diploid genome for you're only going to
use a small part of that huge graph this
represents all of human variation this
represents the hetero zygosity in the
guy or gal that you're analyzing right
so this sample graph is a small part of
it that's actually used in the read
mapping process okay so I won't go into
the details of of how the the calling
algorithm works suffice to say it is a
very very simple calling algorithm it
was roughly illustrated on the previous
slide yeah so we are counting here
basically genotype calls at this point
we're not talking about long-range
phasing at this point I'm going to get
back to that at the end of the talk but
mainly we're calling individual variants
considered as point variants and we're
interested in whether they exist or not
not whether they're correctly phased
with the neighboring variant answer
enough okay every variance is in the
population somewhere right but not at 1%
okay so you're you're confining itself
yourself to some arbitrary threshold
well that community is gonna have to
choose a threshold because obviously the
graph gets too dense if you go crazy
with this right so that's a practical
choice you know most people chose
reasonable thresholds right it looks
it's a thousand genomes data they didn't
include a variant that was only seen
once in the entire thousand genomes kit
that's D and that's not how we built our
graphs okay so so let's look at this now
we're counting the key term here is
number of augmentations so this is how
many times in my new genome which wasn't
you know wasn't normally wasn't part of
my draining training set except for some
of the graphs like snip thousand G we
trained we tested it sorry on these
particular genomes and they actually
were included in snip thousand G so
there was a little cheating on that on
that one but for many cases they the
genomes that we tested on work and so in
order to interpret the genome in a 1:9
to 3/8 we will have to do a certain
number of augmentations for stuff that
we think is unique it wasn't in our
graph in particular if you use for this
case brca2 easy case if you go through
the primary genome reference grch38 for
BRCA you're gonna 37 times you're gonna
have to invent something that's not in
that simple grch38 one chromosome if you
use the B how many examples do we give
for BRCA actual BRCA training 300k so if
you look at the three different versions
of BRCA in an unnatural graph that
doesn't merge anything you're still
going to have to make 13 augmentations
to interpret your data but if you look
at these other cases you can see that we
make quite fewer on average
augmentations so the point is that when
we're using these graphs what you're
looking for is usually already there if
you've built a rich graph and that's
what allows perfect matching much more
often here is more interesting
statistics for a much harder region MHC
where you have to make 4,500
augmentations in the primary structure
but some of these had remarkably fewer
structures fewer fewer alternates that
you had to add
so this shows a win almost to the point
where you add the unmerged graph in this
case with which you know would have
burnt you very heavily in terms of multi
mapping right yeah that totally would
have screwed you if we're discounting
multi mapping you can do as much multi
mapping as you want in this but you're
already getting down there with some of
these other ones and radically fewer
than augmentations than you would have
needed for if you just had grch38
this really I think strongly illustrates
that a bunch of information can be
packed in these graphs without detriment
to the kind of key algorithms that we
need and here's now a comparison on the
Illumina platinum genomes where we have
the state-of-the-art algorithm
essentially the gatk 3 pipeline and
we're looking at 1 - precision here to
make it look like a rock plot versus
recall and this is accuracy on on the
snips and so your your gatk standard
pipeline is this one in teal and this
graph that uses the thousand genomes
baked into it is beating it soundly so
we are calling variants better than the
gatk pipeline how do the graphs look and
how do they compare I'll go through this
really quickly so you can compare two
graphs and again from either a string
comparison - they contain the same 27
MERS in this case or whatever or from a
topology comparison and this jacquard
distance is the usual measurement of the
symmetric difference between 0 or
normalized between 0 & 1 and you can see
the various graphs and how they they
compare here and this is a funny thing
if you just restrict it to the sample
that's being used they are very very
similar down here the difference is
really small sorry this came off the
list but this is 10 to the minus
big number so so on the samples they're
very different whereas a whole graphs
they're quite large so you can have a
very large graph that looks different
from this but when you thread the sample
through it and just look at the part of
the graph that's left after threading
those two different graphs give
virtually the same threading now a
threading of this through the graph what
is what is uh what is the Oxford group
call it chromo type okay it's basically
a partially phased interpretation of
your data right because you're just
gonna have two two lines through this
thing that are occasionally merged and
occasionally split when it's a
heterozygous position so those two
graphs look very similar even when the
whole graphs don't
and then more precise thing this was
funny so we this was fun we did a
topology comparison by the following
reasoning so here you have two graphs
these are very simple graphs they just
have these bases in them as individual
nodes and so every node has one base in
it and you might have a graph a GGT AGT
and then you could have an
interpretation of the sequence AGT that
is the that forms a basis for comparing
these graphs so the overall idea is we
take two graphs we throw a lot of
sequences each of which has a path on
them and then we see whether if we merge
so that they take the same path what we
get and in this case you have two paths
on this graph that are depicted here you
know I could skip the first G or it
could skip the second G and when you try
to merge these two they're common core
you get this graph which is well-defined
so there's a graph homology from here to
here and then there's another graph
homology from here to here and this is
the largest halala G image of these
graphs under that path identification so
there's a nice kind of math behind this
and so you get this graph which
essentially is saying any number of G's
here so that is called the core graph
and so we compared arbitrary graphs by
computing this home maximum home
illogical core graph and these are the
results that we got from that so you can
see actually that these graphs this is
the primary graph the camel graph the
cactus graph are quite similar there's
the finally the scale in in many cases
to each other and they're quite
different from the the brains so this is
a measure of essentially graphs are two
graphs are similar if you merge them so
that all the paths were still
represented in all the paths that both
of them are still represented but you
merge the minimum amount you needed to
in order to achieve that so if they're
identical the common core is the graph
isomorphism between them which is
unfortunately also a hard computational
problem so that's why we use these path
heuristics to compute it but if the
graphs are different in structure then
it forces you to merge out the
differences down to a core that is
essentially a a common Mahama logical
product homology product of those two
graphs so anyhow summary is that the
graph reference has a lot of potential
but we do need more extensive evaluation
there is no one right algorithm that we
found to build it more data is better
that was clear so you have a lot the
people who used a larger amount of human
variation baked into the graph did
better you have an issue of how we're
going to represent haplotype which was
runs things so there's a there's a
difficult trade-off here because as soon
as if I have two different haplotype
genomes and I and so I have two snips
here and here and I merge the stuff in
between them I lose all haplotype
information linking those two snips so
we are now Benedict is now working on a
very interesting new idea that would
recover some of that haplotype
information in an auxilary data
structure because you want to know for
this graph not just how often do I use
note but you kind of want to know how
often I use different paths that are
multi multi node paths and that
information can be cleverly encoded in
an auxilary structure and that would be
very exciting so then these graphs come
become up another level in which they
represent a richer source of human
genetic variation than simply counting
and structuring things so we're very
excited about that
and we want to measure rigorously
whether that improves things like
alignment and variation calling when we
do that
community efforts and so forth so I want
to thank the people that were mostly
involved primarily Benedict Peyton who
led the whole project and the students
that he worked with here that first for
Eric garrison at the Sanger many people
at other institutions including Gil
McVean and I want to thank the Simons
Foundation for funding this thing Thanks
yes
so far Oh wit quite a ways back yeah
there we go
undirected actually the the edges do
have different types but they're by
directed technically right
yeah so it turns out that most edges go
from let's just use left and right most
edges connect the right side of one
sequence to the left side of another but
there are these funny edges that I
showed you in the reversal example that
connect the left side of one block to
the left side of another one or the
right side so we call those reversing
edges so we actually count the cut with
differently for reversing verses regular
or edges technicality but basically yeah
yes there's a cycle you're going to have
a reversing right so so with respect to
this we talked about the left and right
edges and then if there is I'd show you
this but yeah if you have a regular
Snyder
not a reversal but you have a regular
cycle in which you can go back to here
and repeat this again and again and
again right then you must have what's
called a back edge and so this was the
original problem from Nick's paper
feedback arc right so you could ask the
question when I linearly order these and
I impose a direction assume that the
edges are the get rid of the edges that
are three prime to three prime so the
reversing edges are a special thing and
then just classify all the edges and
direct them for it because now they
connect a three prime side and a 5 prime
side or a left side and a right side so
direct them forcibly direct them this
way from the right side to the left side
if you have a cycle in your graph a
normal cycle in your graph you cannot
avoid having one of those directed edges
that goes back so that would be the
feedback arc question and then you might
the natural computer science question is
one order of these minimizes the number
of feedback arcs and welcome to dicks
world right that's np-hard so we use
heuristics to order this and so we do
I'm just telling about cut width but
there's we also count how many feedbacks
you have and how many
how many reversing edges you have and
how they are treated within this the
reversing edges you know don't don't
make a lot of sense within this thing
but the feedbacks do many of the graphs
have zero feedbacks because people like
to build directed acyclic graphs they
get burned when they're trying to
represent inversions and stuff because
they can't or they're trying to
represent if you have to represent a
slippery piece of DNA that might be 13
copies 14 copies 15 copies 17 copies 20
copies and a directed acyclic graph
you've got to choose to represent
explicitly the different paths for the
different number of copies and then you
will top out at some point so it may be
at 20 copies in your graph somebody
comes along with a genome with 21 copies
you can't there's no path in your graph
for that but if you put a loop I can
have as many as I want
well I'm gonna have a feedback arc when
I try to order it yes this major
motivation for this was better
interpretation of RNA so our view and
we're working so we have an RNA seek
task team led by Barbara Wald there Leo
Packer is working very intensively on it
he's got a great new Callisto this new
aligner and or a new RNA abundance
estimator but the key was that we wanted
what many people want to study the
relationship between actual DNA
variation and isoforms specific
expression and it's very hard to do that
in the current format right you you have
just one reference chromosome not
representing the other possibilities so
our view of Arnie is very similar to
this RNA analysis is takes off from this
so we feel that everyone should start
with the reference genome once we've
referenced graph genome so once we have
a graph genome we all like that as most
of the variation we care about in it
then you're analyzing Suzy's DNA and RNA
so you're mapping Suzy's DNA here and
possibly the RNA as well and you find
that you need 246 augmentations to this
graph to fully represent Suzy's DNA and
RNA so you make those ignant ations now
and thereafter whenever you're talking
about RNA expression there's an explicit
path for that isoform in the graph and
you can distinguish that from the other
isoforms that allows you to connect the
genetics with the RNA expression in a
way that's much better than you can
today so this already is a huge argument
for this kind of thing yes t-cells
yes
so you know the t-cell rearrangements we
probably would not see a particular
t-cell rearrangement at a frequency
higher than 1% so they would all be
augmentations so when you did somebody's
genome then you would say ah but I
sequence a bunch of T cells then you're
going to get a bunch of augmentations
for the different T cells and you can
put some stats on there about the
abundance of the T cell clone but this
is all about you know this is an area
where you would have to make possibly
hundreds or thousands of augmentations
in the same place and then you and it'll
break our first tools and you'll have to
fix the tools you're gonna you're gonna
name a diploid position sorry
heterozygous position with the new
character okay so you don't care about
phasing then okay right okay collapse
right right so in that approach these
things would collapse to a new symbol
which meant an AC heterozygote position
interesting idea and I'd like to see a
tool built on top of this that way I
still claim that the community should
keep this richer information as the base
information but then somebody could
write a clever app on top of it to
squeeze it and then then cheat and push
it through worse
pipelines that way you've hit on the key
thing is selling this to the community
you have to get over the oh my god we've
got to recoat our pipeline problem so
that's the issue that's the inertia
oh yeah the better we can adapt tools
the better thank you